for years why I started with a
screenplay that I wrote called drum line
and the director charles stone his
vision for the movie was so close to the
script that I wrote that a lot of
screenwriters told me you'll you'll
never have an experience like that where
exactly what you intended on the page is
so close to what the director's vision
of it was and as I went along working as
a screenwriter in the industry I began
to see that that was such a special
experience I wrote on the set I worked
with the actors and drum line and so
eventually I learned it is the
director's vision and his medium or her
medium in this case and and slowly but
surely that desire in me to direct began
and I didn't want to have that gap
between what I was writing on the page
and what the vision was of the director
and the details of the script became
more and more important to me as I wrote
and when I got to people's because it's
a comedy and african-american families
sometimes are not given the opportunity
to sort of have this kind of dry wit
sometimes quirky if I didn't protect
that tone as the director I was really
worried about giving a comedy to the
world that I didn't have that kind of
tone so that's what kind of pushed me
and then my producer Stephanie Elaine we
had a very really early on I had met
with her when I did not want to I didn't
really think I should direct this
because it was a big cast singing
dancing dogs like everything that would
make me say do not do this but in the
conversation that I first had with her
she felt that it was mine to direct and
she kind of encouraged me and championed
me to do that because there's so few
African American films it with drum line
with atl I noticed in a lot of my work I
try to hit many generations because I
sort of think about that I want mom to
go dad to go teenagers to go and
so I try to cover sort of a broad sense
of comedy and hit moments that everybody
in the family might enjoy and with the
cast I started with Kerry Washington and
she was the first person that I thought
of for people's even though she doesn't
have a comedic background she sort of
has this type a perfectionism about her
like Kerry does I would just watch her
and you just sent her know she's got it
together and she's very studied and
prepared and I felt like if she would
play with us and sort of make fun of
that kind of perfectionism that it would
be funny as the straight man with Craig
and I wanted to sell that she really
came from a striving family and a family
where high achievement was important and
even over the comedy I knew Kerry could
sell that and then she just ended up
being totally funny in the movie so it
was a bonus and and in the case of
diahann carroll and melvin van peebles
bay it was day one that we were shooting
there there's their scenes and so I had
a meltdown but it didn't occur to me
until I was going to set that okay this
is melvin van peebles diahann carroll
and then it started snowing and I and
then the ad is like well we have to
block it now inside and so I just
remember having just this quiet meltdown
that day and Diahann Carroll unknowing
that I was needed a moment just gave a
speech to the cast because she had
followed them as fans and noticed their
choices were really smart and was
excited to come play with them and
playing she doesn't do much comedy but
she doesn't do comedy she rarely works
and by choice she's very selective so to
ask her to play sort of a frisky modern
as she called it grandmother made my
heart like have palpitations but she
made this speech on the first day and
Melvin as well and it set the tone for
the movie and it kind of gave me a
minute to come back inside my body and
we had a great shoot so I thank them for
that I did have a theory with casting I
would pick African Americans that might
be third row from the back and a cool
Apatow movie
he might be like he had that line he was
so funny but um um many times Craig this
is his first leading role and and
carries for comedy like I just sort of
you know twisted everybody and how you
expected to see them kali hawk also she
had funny lines in bridesmaids like a in
and out of bridesmaids and that's where
I saw her and I was like oh yeah kali
hawk will be good at gala or um malcolm
barrett he's a new stand-up comic that
played Craig Robinson's brother in the
movie and kimrie she played Meg the
girlfriend of Gloria people's these this
was a big opportunity for us especially
as an african-american cast to break new
faces to break new leading men it's it's
something that's a struggle in our
system and so that's one of my proudest
achievements as a new director to bring
new voices to the screen that we don't
we don't get as many chances so I'm I
think I'm most proud of that